how hard was the decision
and uh i mean maybe you can tell me what
instagram looked in the beginning but
how hard was it to make
pictures the first class citizen that's
a revolutionary idea
like um at whatever point instagram
became this feed
of
photos that's quite brilliant
plus
i also don't know when this happened but
they're all shaped the same
it's like i have to tell you why that's
the interesting part
why is that so a couple of things one is
data data like you're right you can over
interpret data like imagine trying to
fly a plane
by staring at
i don't know a single metric like
airspeed
you don't know if you're going up or
down i mean it correlates with up or
down but you don't actually know will
never help you land the plane
so don't stare at one metric like it
turns out you have to synthesize a bunch
of metrics to know where to go
um but it doesn't lie like if your air
speed is zero unless it's not working
right if it's zero
you're probably going to fall out of the
sky so
generally you look around and you have
the scan going yes
and you're just asking yourself is this
working or is this not working
um
but people have trouble explaining
how they actually feel
so just it's about synthesizing both of
them so then instagram right uh uh we
were talking about revolutionary moment
where where the feed became
square photos basically and photos first
and then square footage yeah um
it was clear to me that the biggest so
i believe the biggest companies are
founded
when
enormous technical shifts happen and the
biggest technical shift that happened
right before instagram was founded was
the advent of a phone that didn't suck
the iphone right like in retrospect
we're like oh my god the first iphone
that almost had like it wasn't that good
but compared to everything else at the
time it was
amazing
and by the way the first uh phone that
had an incredible camera
that could that could like do as well as
the point-and-shoot you might carry
around
was the iphone 4 and that was right when
instagram launched and we looked around
and we said what will change because
everyone has a camera in their pocket
and it was so clear to me that the the
world of
social networks before
it was based in the desktop and sitting
there and having a link you could share
right
and that wasn't going to be the case the
question is what would you share if you
were out and about in the world
if not only did you have a camera that's
in your pocket but by the way that
camera had a network attached to it that
allowed you to share instantly
that seemed revolutionary and a bunch of
people saw it at the same time it wasn't
just instagram there were a bunch of
competitors
um the thing we did
i think was not only well we focused on
two things so we wrote down those things
we circled photos and we said i think we
should invest in this
but then we said what sucks about photos
one
they look like crap right they just at
least back then now
my phone takes pretty great photos right
um back then they were blurry not so
great compressed right
two uh it was really slow
like really slow to upload a photo
and i'll tell a fun story about that and
explain to you why they're all the same
size and square as well
um and three
man if you wanted to share a photo on
different networks you had to go to each
of the individual apps and select all of
them and upload individually and
so we're like all right those are the
pain points we're going to focus on that
so one instead of
because they weren't beautiful um we're
like why don't we lean into the fact
that they're not beautiful and i
remember studying in florence my
photography teacher gave me this holget
camera and i'm not sure everyone knows
what a whole gay camera is but they're
these old school plastic cameras
i think they're produced in china at the
time
and they're i want to say the original
ones were like from the 70s or the 80s
or something they're supposed to be like
three dollar cameras for the every
person
they took nice medium format films large
large
negatives but they kind of blurred the
the the light and they kind of like
light leaked into the side and
there was this whole resurgence where
people looked at that and said oh my god
this is a style right
and i remember using that in florence
and just saying well why don't we just
like lean into the fact that these
photos suck and make them suck more
but in an artistic way and it turns out
that had product market fit people
really liked that they were willing to
share their not so great photos if they
looked not so great on purpose okay
the second part
that's the where the filters come into
the picture yep so computational
modification of photos to make them look
extra crappy to where it becomes art
yeah yeah and
i mean
add light leaks add like an overlay
filter make them more contrasty than
they should be the first
filter we ever produced was called x pro
two and i designed it while i was in
this small little bed and breakfast room
in total santos mexico i was trying to
take a break from the
the bourbon days and i i remember saying
to my co-founder i just need like a week
to reset
and that was
on that trip worked on the first filter
because i said you know i think i can do
this and i literally iterated
one by one over the rgb values in the
array that was the photo
and just slightly shifted basically
there was a function of our function of
g function of b
that just shifted them slightly it
wasn't rocket science um and it turns
out that actually made your photo look
pretty cool
it just mapped from one color space to
another color space
it was simple but it was really slow i
mean if you applied a filter
i think it used to take two or three
seconds to render
only eventually would i figure out how
to do it on the gpu and i'm not even
sure it was gpu but was using opengl but
anyway um i would eventually figure that
out and then it would be instant but it
used to be really slow by the way anyone
who's watching or listening
it's amazing what you can get away with
in a startup
as long as the product
outcome is right for the user like you
can be slow you can be terrible you can
be
as long as you have product market fit
people will put up with a lot and then
the question is just about compressing
making it more performant over time so
that they get that product market fit
instantly
so fascinating because there's some
things where
those three seconds would
make or break the app but some things
you're saying not it's hard to know when
you know it's what it's the problem
spotify solved
making streaming
like
work
and
like delays in listening to music is a
huge negative
even like slight delays
but here you're saying i mean how do you
know
when those three seconds are okay or
you're just gonna have to
try it out because to me my intuition
would be
those three seconds would kill the app
like i would try to do the opengl thing
right
so i wish i were that smart at the time
um
i wasn't i just knew how to do what i
knew how to do right
and i decided okay like why don't i just
iterate over the values and change them
and what's interesting
is that um
compared to the alternatives no one else
used opengl right so everyone else was
doing it the dumb way and in fact they
were doing it at a high resolution now
comes in the small resolution that we'll
talk about for a second
um
by choosing 512 pixels by 512 pixels
which i believe it was at the time
we iterated over a lot fewer pixels than
our competitors who were trying to do
these enormous output like images yeah
so instead of taking 20 seconds i mean
three seconds feels pretty good right
so on a relative basis we were winning
like a lot
okay so that's answer number one answer
number two is uh
we actually focused on latency in the
right places so we did this really
wonderful thing um
when you uploaded so uh the way it would
work is you know you'd take your phone
you take the
photo and then you'd go to the um
you'd go the edit screen where you would
caption
and on that caption screen you start
typing you think okay like what's a
clever caption and and i said to mike
hey when i worked on the gmail team you
know what they did when you typed in
your username or your email address
even before you've entered in your
password like the chant probability once
you enter in your username that you're
going to actually sign in is extremely
high
so why not just start loading your
account in the background not not like
sending it down to the desktop that
would be a security uh uh
issue but like load it into memory on
the server like get it ready prepare it
i always thought that was so fascinating
and unintuitive i was like mike why
don't we just do that but like we'll
just upload the photo and like assume
you're gonna upload the photo and if you
don't
forget about it we'll delete it right
so what ended up happening was people
would caption their uh photo they'd
press done or upload
and you'd see this little progress bar
just go
it was lightning fast okay
we were no faster than anyone else at
the time but by choosing 512 by 512 and
doing in the background it almost
guaranteed that it was done by the time
you captioned
and everyone when they used it was like
how the hell is this thing so fast
but we were slow we just hit the the
slowness it wasn't like
these things are just like it's a shell
game you're just hiding the latency
that
that mattered to people like a lot and i
think that so you were willing to put up
with a slow filter if it meant you could
share it immediately and of course we
added sharing options which let you
distribute it really quickly that was
the third part
um
so latency matters but relative to what
and then
there's some like tricks you could get
around to just hiding the latency um
like i don't know if spotify starts
downloading the next song eagerly i'm
assuming they do
there are a bunch of ideas here that are
not rocket science that
that really help
and all of that was
stuff you were explicitly having a
discussion about like
those designs and argument you were
having like arguments discussions
uh i'm sure it was arguments i mean
i'm not sure if you've met my co-founder
mike but he's a pretty nice guy
and he's very reasonable and uh
and we both just saw eye to eye and
we're like yeah just like
make this fast early seem fast
it'll be great i mean honestly i think
the most contentious thing and he would
say this too initially
was
um i was on an iphone 3g so like the
not so fast one and he had a brand new
iphone 4. that was cheap nice um
and his feed loaded super smoothly like
when he would scroll from photo to photo
buttery smooth right but on my phone
every time you got to a new photo it was
like
chunk allocate memory like all this
stuff right
i was like mike that's unacceptable he's
like oh come on man just like upgrade
your phone basically you didn't actually
say that he's nicer than that um
but i could tell he wished like i would
just stop being cheap and just get a new
phone
but what's funny is we actually sat
there working on that little detail for
a few days before launch and
that polished experience plus the fact
that uploading seemed fast for all these
people who didn't have nice phones
i think meant a lot
because
far too often you see teams focus not on
performance they focus on
what's the cool computer science problem
they can solve
right can we scale this thing to a
billion users and they've got like 100
right
yeah
you talked about loss function so i want
to come back to that
but like the loss function is like do
you provide a great happy magical
whatever experience for the consumer
and listen if it happens to involve
something complex and technical then
great
but it turns out i think most of the
time
those experiences are just sitting there
waiting to be built with like not that
complex solutions
uh but everyone is just like so stuck in
their own head that they have to over
engineer everything and then they forget
about the easy stuff
i mean also maybe to flip the lost
function there is you're trying to
minimize the number of times
you there's unpleasant experience right
like the one you mentioned where when
you go to the next photo it freezes for
a little bit so it's almost as opposed
to maximizing pleasure it's probably
easier to minimize
the number of like the friction
yeah and as we all know you just you
just uh you just make the pleasure
negative and then minimize everything so
okay we're mapping this all back to
neural networks but actually can i say
one thing on that which is
i don't know a lot about machine
learning but i feel like i've i've tried
studying a bunch the whole idea of
reinforcement learning
and planning out more than the greedy
single experience i think is
is the closest you can get to
like ideal product design thinking
where you're not saying hey like can we
have a great experience just this one
time but like what is the right way to
onboard someone what series of
experiences correlate most with them
hanging on long term
right so not just saying oh did the
photo load slowly a couple times or did
they get a great photo at the top of
their feed
but like what are the things that are
going to make this person come back
over the next week over the next month
and as a product designer asking
yourself okay i want to optimize not
just minimize bad experiences in the
short run but like
how do i get someone to engage over the
next month
and i'm not gonna claim at all that i
thought that way at all at the time
because i certainly didn't but if i were
going back and giving myself any advice
it would be thinking what are those what
are those second order effects that you
can create
and it turns out having your friends on
the service is an enormous win so
starting with a very small group of
people that produce content that you
wanted to see which we did we seeded the
community very well i think
ended up mattering and
so
you